Hey David, this is a funny question.
Hey David, can you tell us the truth about
what's going on with your belly button?
I know people who had appendectomies and very
strange things happened to their belly buttons.
Can you come clean?
All right.
This is sort of weird and personal, but I
will briefly mention it.
Maybe this is not the right story to listen
to if you're having breakfast or something
right now.
So on October 2nd I had an emergency appendectomy.
They tend to always be emergencies as far
as I know, and it was fortunately laparoscopic
rather than an open of my uh, abdomen.
This means that three small incisions are
made indeed.
One of those incisions was just below my belly
button.
That is the one according to my surgeon who
was great, who said, and again this I, I'm
going into detail here.
He said, that is the incision through which
the appendix is removed.
There is no doubt that after, in fact, when
I was still sort of on anesthesia, I remember
lifting my shirt and looking down to see what
was going on and it was not good.
My entire stomach had been shaved.
I had a surgical glue and stitches and it
was, it was crazy.
Uh, but I'll tell you the truth, I was convinced
my belly button would remain looking very,
very different forever because it looked so
different after the, um, the, the surgery,
it turns out that like 90% of it was just
the surgical glue that they use, which has
kind of a purple color as that fell off.
And again, I apologize if it's too much information
here, but people ask as that fell off, uh,
the belly buttons really looking pretty good.
You still see the incision, of course, it's
totally scarred over at this point and it
still hurts the tiniest bit sometimes in certain
positions.
But now that the hair has grown back in, I'm
really pretty pleased I have to say with how
my, uh, belly button is looking.
Thank you to the have very good handiwork
of, uh, dr Matthew NAES over at Faulkner hospital
in Boston because you really did a very good
job.
Uh, and I, the, the belly button is looking
fine, so I appreciate the concern.
Assuming that this was not a trolling question
and, um, it's kind of weird, uh, to even be
going in this direction.
But that is the answer and I have nothing
else to say about it and don't know that I
will have anything more in the future.
We've got a great bonus show for you today,
producer Pat.
Taking the reins of the Friday bonus show,
we will see you then.
Sign up, get instant access at, join pacman.com
or patrion.com/david [inaudible], the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com.